this video is brought to you by keeps
[Music]
what's up guys michael here and today
we're talking about the only secret
agent who can say his name faster than
sterling archer that's right her name is
bond
james bond he's one of just a few iconic
characters to have been portrayed on the
big screen by a host of different actors
and he's almost the only one who isn't
either a superhero super villain or a
member of the british royal family
nowadays it's not weird to talk about
who's gonna play the new bond but the
idea of recasting the character was once
so unthinkable that they considered
writing in a plastic surgery subplot to
explain why sean connery now looked
australian so what makes bond so
malleable what does the character
continue to inspire after so many
different portrayals and what can each
portrayal tell us about the era it was
made for let's find out in this
wisecrack edition on why james bond
won't die spoilers ahead for most of the
bond movies but before we dive in i want
to give a quick shout out to this week's
sponsor keeps keeps is a subscription
service that makes it easier and more
affordable for guys to treat hair loss
for most guys a good hair day is an
essential part of feeling confident
about their looks this means that losing
that hair can be stressful for lots of
guys and since two out of three men will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 we
really mean this affects a lot of guys
the good news is that prevention is key
and with the right plan you can keep
those luscious locks you can get started
with a free consultation with a licensed
keeps doctor who can help you get both
fda approved prescriptions and
over-the-counter medications shipped
directly to your home your hair loss
prevention medication will then
automatically arrive every three months
so you won't have to worry about waiting
in long pharmacy lines while being
taunted by discount halloween candy and
you can message your keeps doctor 24 7
to ask any questions and update on your
progress you'll find out why keeps has
more five star reviews than any of its
competitors and why hundreds of
thousands of men trust keeps for their
hair loss prevention if you're ready to
take action to prevent hair loss go to
keeps.com
wisecrack or click the link in the
description to receive 50 off your first
order that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
wisecrack now
back to the show we're going to focus on
the four most influential bonds because
you have others to do and we have a
deadline but before we get to that it's
important to understand who ian
fleming's original bond was in the first
place when he first scribbled him onto
the page in 1953 fleming was looking for
a character who could restore a sense of
adventuring awe-inspiring britishness to
a country that had just limped out of
the second world war the sun was finally
beginning to set on its cherished empire
basically the brits needed a bedtime
story to soothe the pain of no longer
being allowed to own entire countries
drawing on his military and intelligence
experience fleming wrote james bond as
exactly this sort of globe trouting
gentleman the secret agent moves through
the world with a colonizer's confidence
stiff upper lip stoicism and endless
supply of dinner jackets however when it
came time for fleming to bring his
creation to the big screen there were
some concerns about whether american
audiences would connect with such an
overwhelmingly british protagonist they
even tried to americanize him for an
early tv series leading to the only
official version of bond ever to be
called
jimmy card sense jimmy bond they call
you i knew you right away fortunately a
certain scotsman then strolled into
frame to put things right sean connery's
version of the character was in some
ways already a serious pivot from the
great british cheerleader fleming had
envisioned his thick accent and
self-deprecating charm marked him as a
slightly more rugged working-class
figure lavra thanks you for saving his
life you are now his son
oh thank you more reminiscent of the
straight talking gunslingers that
american audiences were used to he had a
steady stream of quippy one-liners many
of which connery improvised i will wear
this one
in
piccadilly you won't
they've just passed some new laws there
the actor's athletic presence which the
producers called his animal magnetism as
well as his cock-sure confidence
guaranteed that he would remain an
enduring sex symbol according to bob
mccabe in his biography of the legendary
actor connery's bond was a sensualist a
man who pleased himself first and
foremost and damned the consequence a
classless hero a man who made his own
rules and walked in a world of his own
creating connery imbued the character
with a certain ironic detachment from
the whole business of britishness with
all its delineated pecking orders while
fleming's bond was designed as the very
personification of his nation connery's
strength comes from his lack of
definitive ties to the queen sure he was
out there protecting crown and country
but he always seemed at least as
interested in drinking his martinis and
doing sex as he wasn't protecting the
motherland who are you
my name is [ __ ] galore
i must be dreaming this was fitting for
the swinging 60s the pre-women's
liberation era of alcohol-soaked
playboys like jfk and frank sinatra and
connery's reinvention of bond was
absolutely vital to the character's
success he made him a hero fit for the
time and for an international audience
instead of just an ode to one nation's
sense of faded glory the formula for
bringing bond onto the big screen was
effectively written certain details had
to remain in place like his charm on the
guns
the gun of course talent for violence
and fine fashion sense but the details
can be changed to suit the time and
place of course connery famously loathed
portraying the renegade secret agent and
eventually dropped out of the series the
next iconic bond would be roger moore
who took up the mantle in
1973. in doing so he restored a sense of
social elegance and sophistication to
the character while also pushing the
series in a notably more lighthearted
direction moore's bond didn't have
connery's smoldering sexuality or bad
boy appeal and while his films leaned
into the character's womanizing even
more heavily than before his politeness
and propriety smoothed off the rougher
edges of bond's machismo he generally
seemed more like an amateur sommelier
than mr steel your girl and on the
surface that might seem like a return to
fleming's bond blueprint this was a bond
who was comfortable in the high class
surroundings which connery had made a
mockery of he exemplified the kind of
mannered intelligence and strategic
brilliance that the british empire
wanted to retain as its personal brand
the only problem was that morris bond
was also the campiest he corralled with
ladies named holly goodhead and got
attacked by ice hockey players
altogether these were ludicrous
semi-periodic films rather than serious
spy thrillers but more was very much in
on the joke portraying bond as a larger
than life lightly humorous figure a
pleasant evening and that may not have
been exactly what fleming had in mind
once again though it was the bond the
audience wanted he was more of an
uncomplicated good guy who the whole
family could cheer for everything else
about his adventures reflected this
desire for light entertainment too the
villains became even more over the top
and the gadgets got notably goofier can
anyone get me like a shoe that has a
knife inside of it does anyone have a
pair of flip-flops that become handcuffs
can someone get me a hat that has a
special gadget where your parents tell
you they love you and your ears this was
all reflective of the general
spoof-happy ambiance of 1970s hollywood
the periodic nature reflected a cultural
shift away from that whole idea of
nationalistic heroism the further
audiences moved away from the black and
white of world war ii and into the messy
grey of vietnam the less appetite there
was for stories which presented fighting
for your country as the epitome of good
so
they opted for escapism instead
and moore's winking presentation of the
character gave the viewer permission not
to take anything they saw too seriously
you suggest the trade
the egg
for your life
right here the price of eggs was going
up but isn't that a little high and when
pierce brosnan came on the scene to play
90s bond he maintained this comedic
self-awareness well i must say
i've had a lovely evening you
once again the pleasure was all yours
his version of double07 was like moore's
all about zany gadgets and facing off
against absurd villains and somewhat
like more brosten generally plays these
moments for laughs leaning into the
absurdity of it all so that the audience
can enjoy the sheer escapism of the
whole crazy tale but he wasn't just a
copy and paste of morris character after
swinging between social classes and
previous depictions brosnan's bond
seemed like neither a fussy elite nor a
rough-edged working man as journalist
denisha smith explains the irish-born mr
brosnan has an indeterminate accent not
quite high english not quite connery a
reflection perhaps of the breakdown of
english class lines his sexuality was
similarly caught between connery's
roguish darkness and moore's gentlemanly
gentleness in many ways he embodied the
whole metrosexual trend which came to
prominence in the 90s he maintained the
emotional restraint and violent
potential of traditional bond machismo
wrapped in an outer layer of
soft-skinned delicate good looks
basically he was the first bond who
looked like he had a solid skincare
routine locked in this was a bond for a
new era a post-cold war world in which
the old hierarchies were being
challenged at least to some degree it
wasn't just the way he looked or spoke
but the whole way this new bond had to
interact with the world around him the
hetero male fantasy which the character
represented would no longer go totally
unscrutinized good
because i think you're a sexist
misogynist dinosaur a relic of the cold
war and the movie's female characters
were no longer just there to roll around
in bed with bond they were kicking ass
right alongside him or growing immune to
his charms out on some kind of
professional assignment addressing the
kill
you know you'll find this crushing 07.
when i don't sit at home every night
praying for some international incident
so i can run down here all dressed up to
impress james bond the brosnan bond
movies were an attempt to find a place
for the character in an era of evolving
gender norms that mainstream
entertainment was expected to at least
pay lip service to they even use the
question is there still a place in the
modern world for a secret agent like 007
in promotional materials explicitly
playing to the idea of bond as an
anachronism rather than hiding from it
and while the boston bond movies were
still too light-hearted to fully
persuade us of bond's contemporary
relevance the man who would inherit his
double o status would be far better
equipped in a sense the broodier
bloodier direction which daniel craig
took the bond franchise was really the
only place for it to go by 2006. after
years of full-blown parodies like austin
powers and johnny english took aim at
all the series tropes and cliches the
goofy self-deprecating humor of boston
and more just wouldn't really work
anymore what are you feeding him
why don't you just kill him
no scott i have an even better idea i'm
going to place him in an easily
escapable situation involving an overly
elaborate and exotic death so you
couldn't really expect an audience to
sit through that style of a bond movie
again with a straight face and at the
same time the success of the bourne
movies had ushered in an era of more
serious grounded spy thrillers james
bond couldn't just be a well-groomed
jokester anymore he had to be convincing
as a trained killer and more
fundamentally as an actual human being
we needed a bond who could do the
heavier lifting dramatically speaking
that was expected of a spy thriller in
the 21st century enter daniel craig when
craig emerges from the water glistening
under the sun and showing off his newly
bolt up body it's not just for the eye
candy it's making us viscerally aware of
bond's body so that we can watch the
toll his work is going to take
the craig bond films highlight the
battering that he takes throughout each
mission showing his injuries and all
their grisly detail and emphasizing the
gruesome things he has to put himself
through just to stay alive
bond still made plenty of time for games
of chance and romantic dalliances but
the true stakes of his behavior are
always made clear he lives a life of
constant danger not freewheeling fun and
his more devil may care decisions often
come with devastating consequences look
how well your charm works james the
protagonist might still be handsome and
quick with the line can you kill him
yes
will you
someone usually dies but he was someone
whose whole life revolves around doing
ugly
often morally questionable things and
this fact was reflected in the haunted
hard-drinking new version of the
character vocal martini chicken was
stirred do i look like i gave it down as
much as he tries to maintain the
character's signature steely exterior
this is the first bond we see carrying
his emotional wounds from film to film i
wanted to be a pretty co-bastard didn't
want revenge for the death of someone he
loved
you don't have to worry about me
i'm not gonna go chasing him he's not
important
neither was she in every other iteration
double 07 seemed to reset completely
between missions the agent turning up as
crisp and clean as his new dinner suit
by the time craig's version gets to
skyfall the psychological and physical
toll of being james bond is made
painfully clear medical evaluation
failed
physical evaluation failed
psychological evaluation alcohol and
substance addiction indicated
this moody brooding bond was not one
designed for nationalistic myth-making
but for a post-9 11 world in which the
brutality and ambiguity of global
conflicts was being broadcasted daily
it's a revisionist portrayal which owns
the physical and psychological damage
which a real-life james bond would
undergo it still gave audiences the
debonair all-action fantasy they'd come
to expect but it also complicated it
forcing them to reckon with his coldness
and his brutality so at the end of the
day bond has not only survived
explosions bullet wounds and razor
rimmed hats but he's withstood the
passage of time more successfully than
almost any other pop culture figure so
we're left with the same question that
everyone from dr no to blofeld was
agonized over why is james bond so damn
hard to kill the answer might lie in the
fact that as an international man of
mystery the question of who double 07
exactly is has always been intentionally
shrouded in uncertainty scholar
christopher lindner suggests that the
key to bond's longevity is his status as
a highly unstable and often ambiguous
cultural icon from his inception bond
has always been less of a flesh and
blood man than a kind of ideal his
height hair color accent and general
character have all changed massively
over the years as he has gone from
blowing up bad guys with explosive
toothpaste dentonite toothpaste to be
used sparingly
it's the latest in plastic explosive to
battling the gruesome effects of age and
alcoholism and author craig owens argues
that bond is not the collection of
various characteristics rather he is the
blank middle they fill in he is an
opening a vacant unclaimed potentiality
rather than an ontologically assignable
identity and so we get to fill bond's
famed tuxedo with whoever we need him to
be at that moment in history his
adventures have adapted to our changing
taste with the campy gadget-filled
iterations of the 90s giving way to the
grittier more grounded style of the
2000s we were expecting an exploding pen
we don't really go in for that anymore
as a result bond is able to retain his
appeal from one decade to the next even
his taste and trends change completely
with a new incarnation of the character
arriving tailor-made to meet each
audience's demands but what do you guys
think will there eventually come a day
where james bond simply has to be put
into retirement or is he such a potent
impliable symbol that we can keep
reinventing him forever let us know in
the comments thanks as always to our
patrons for all your support and
remember to check out our podcast
wrestle that subscribe button like it's
a pre-cgi shark and don't forget to ring
that bell and as always thanks for
watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]